Good morning, John. Today has to be an update.
There's just too much going on.
So, update in nine parts starting now:
Shooting The Fault in Our Stars movie is wrapping up and while I have really enjoyed this really unique
behind-the-scenes look from the perspective of a total noob that is you,
I'm kind of glad to have you back
'cause somebody needs to explain debt ceilings to me.
Part two: Subbable is doing amazingly.
Wheezy Waiter's on there now. Mystery Guitar Man,
C.G.P. Grey, Minute Physics, Beer & Board Games
Woodworking for Mere Mortals...
All you woodworking fans out there?
Subbable for the last two months has averaged a hundred thousand dollars a month paid out to partners.
Three: I've been in several recent episodes
of Wheezy Waiter's "The Good Stuff". There's links in the description.
Four: I'm headed to San Franc...
Ugh, doorbell.
It was a package from Daily Grace, which is super weird. I have - I did not expect -
I'm trying to open this with a -
staple remover. I'm just gonna stab it with a pen.
Oh my god, that's a really soft pen!
Scissors, they were there - they were there the whole time.
I wonder if it's something to drink. It says, "A belated gift to say thank you for a wonderful VidCon."
This is amazing.
Oh my God. It is a drink! It's Hendrix!
(Laughs)
I can't believe I called it.
Also, "You've been hazed!
What a sweetheart. Anyway, as I was saying, I'm going to San Francisco for an EDU Conference at YouTube.
I'm excited for good ideas and things.
DFTBA records is going well. Here I am at the warehouse.
We're getting ready for Christmas and also the Lizzie Bennet Kickstarter,
which I'm sorry we haven't sent out yet, but at the moment there's not a lot to do.
We actually have a new vlog series called "The Warehouse"
starring one of our warehouse workers, Matthew -
he films right over here - and this is the fort he built out of overstock boxes. It's called Fort Awesome.
I didn't realize, but this one - these are all still signed.
We still have lots of signed John Green posters here.
Quite a while ago, I sat right here
and I told you about my idea for turning a Jane Austen book into a video blog series.
That thing, "The Lizzie Bennet Diaries",
did very well - tens of millions of views. It won an Emmy.
I'm excited to sit here again and tell you that we're doing it again, this time with Jane Austen's "Emma".
I think that telling stories in different ways is really fascinating and we're going to continue exploring that.
Probably in some more new different exciting ways.
But you'll have to go to youtube.com/pemberleydigital to watch and see what we're up to.
Thank you to all of you who love and supported the Lizzie Bennet diaries
I really hope that you like "Emma Approved" as well.
Also John and I are helping out with the Harry Potter Alliance's Equality for the Win Indiegogo campaign.
There are a bunch of really great perks.
There's an excerpt from "The Price of Dawn", the fictional novel from "The Fault in Our Stars", written by John.
I wrote a Harry Potter fanfic called "The Womb of Requirement",
which is like an origin story for the Room of Requirement.
It's going to be read into like an audiobook kind of thing - by Evanna Lynch!
Nyah! It will be available for not very much longer, midnight, Pacific Time, Saturday.
So yes, there's a lot going to be on and to be honest I'm a little fret - a lot going to be on?
Yep. Take on maybe a couple more responsibilities than I should occasionally.
But I feel like I have like responsibility to the world, to you John, and to Nerdfighteria,
and I, you know, I really appreciate that
I have opportunities to do all these cool things
and how can you say no?
And then sometimes you just get somebody being really nice and sending you gin.
Oh, Grace... More like, daily disgrace!
So yeah lots of stuff going on.
If you're having a hard time following it, we are on whatever social network you prefer.
Newly Google+!
I've talked about a lot of things in this video. There's links to all of them in the description.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Katherine just got back from the dentist.
How's your face?
-What face?
Mop mop mop mop
mop mop
-Wanna go watch a show?
-Gonna eat some mashed potatoes.
-Okay.
-Mah-poh-tah-toes.
(Laughs)
Poh-tah-toes.